[Applause]
what a show
happy wednesday good to see michael
loftus is back
here he is uh getting food from the same
place he gets his clothes
[Laughter]
the only thing worse than loftus's
clothes is when he's not wearing any
and i know
and the judge has joined us
judge janine
just
just made it here in time here is she is
she arriving at the studio
[Music]
[Applause]
when we say here comes the judge it's a
warning
but but sadly we have some breaking news
uh our 11 p.m competition over at msnbc
is quitting
oh no no oh stop it
sad time judge oh yes after being
regularly shellacked by this little
juggernaut of a show brian williams
announced he got tired of lying i mean
losing
and announced he's leaving the network
shocking yeah don't stop it
the more you clap the less i talk
but who knew he was still employed
but let's be honest he's not leaving
without racking up some key achievements
sure he was known to fabricate stuff but
in the writing world it's known as
poetic license in the news world it's
known as being a dishonest sacrifice
but he still he still had quite the
resume especially when you hear it from
him
i had an illustrious career voted people
magazine's sexiest man alive from 1980
to 1990 all while leading the pittsburgh
steelers to four straight supermans
i couldn't have done it without my wife
angelina jolie
and my other wife
cleopatra who i married in a secret
seance in the lost city of atlantis
i'll finish my memoirs which will focus
on my discovery of the polio vaccine and
my charity work feeding orphans inside a
volcano
i'm made out of pillows
good night and good luck
by the way edward r murrow stole that
from me
so as you know there's a trial going on
for kyle rittenhouse but it seems to be
collapsing like brian stelter after
doing two jumping jacks
a quick recap it began with the police
shooting of a violent knife-wielding
felon in kenosha wisconsin back in
august 2020 following three days of
riots and property destruction or what
cnn would call peaceful protests
ritenous traveled to kenosha armed with
a rifle publicly stating his mission was
to protect businesses and victims in the
ensuing melee he shot and killed two
people and wounded a third the state of
wisconsin alleges he's a murderer his
defenders and anybody with an iq over 15
describe it as self-defense
and if you listen to the clueless
prosecution they're pretty much proving
it was self-defense too i haven't seen
someone this inept in court since
michael avenatti
as legal
as legal expert james gagliano in the
new york post points out with video
footage from the scene in witness
accounts murder remains an impossible
charge to prove now i've not watched
much of the actual trial i don't have
time what with having two hit shows and
my night job as a bouncer at jojo's
leather and latex tea house
before i met the judge
so let's
but let's see how the media portrays
rittenhouse
kyle rittenhouse the 17 year old
vigilante kyle rittenhouse a vigilante
kyle rittenhouse the armed teenage
vigilante ridden house is basically what
you would have had in a school shooter
he was going out to shoot people just
running around
shooting and killing protesters a 17
year old vigilante
arguably a domestic terrorist a white
trump supporting
maga loving who was radicalized by
trumpism took his ar-15 to kenosha and
became a killer
it's amazing how they can sound exactly
the same but uniquely stupid in their
own way
especially that last guy there's
something wrong with him but you know if
i didn't know any better i think they
were all actors working from the same
script one where they started with the
ending then changed every other word to
racist they're more predictable than a
threes company marathon but here's
something from my favorite cnn legal
analyst
what kind of idiot
17 year old gets a giant gun and goes to
a riot he has no license he has no
training he thinks he's going to scrub
graffiti off with his ar-15 i mean the
stupidity of this like what could
possibly go wrong well a lot went wrong
that's a kick tubin said you have to be
more responsible before you whip
something out
but he should know if you point
something at people there's a chance
it'll go off
what a
dip
anyway meanwhile an abc news summary
focused on the lone survivor of
rittenhouse's actions like he was some
navy seal hunted by the taliban rather
than pursuing rittenhouse it was a great
narrative until you get to the last few
graphs of abc's coverage and you find
this
it wasn't until you pointed your gun at
him
advanced on him with your gun now your
hands down pointed at him
that he fired
correct
[Laughter]
whoops
so the guy wounded by ridden house
admits he was pointing his gun at ritton
house when he was shot
that's no tiny detail if someone walks
towards me with a gun drawn it's either
a threat or i've wandered into dana
perino's yard
look at the prosecutors when the story
didn't go as planned it's the same
reaction my doctor has when i remove my
pants
this trial blew up in their faces like
an antifa made pipe bomb
maybe they should have worn masks
but forget the laughable prosecution
what's concerning is how the media
portrays the actual facts the witness
gage grass krauts
lied about having a gun
that admits he pointed a loaded gun at
ridden house gage
which is a bad name to have in a
firearms case
it's like being named glock or caliber
or alec baldwin
you turned out to be a terrible witness
for the prosecution
but that's on how the media is covering
it to them it's not self-defense at all
it's got to be murder open and shut
because as usual they're as crooked as
an auntie pretzel with scoliosis
so if rittenhouse is found not guilty
how will the activist class react who
were spoon-fed the false media narrative
let's put it this way home depot is
going to have a run on plywood from
small business owners it's almost as if
the media wants to prime the rioters to
think rittenhouse got away with murder
and why well it keeps them from ever
admitting they're wrong they run from
facts like hunter biden runs from a baby
mama
but it guarantees more violence which
they see as restorative justice and
ratings too brian williams picked the
wrong time to retire fact is it was the
media's embrace of the riots while
condemning the police that led to more
unbridled violence and when there's no
law enforcement who fills that gap i'll
give you a hint it's not social workers
or mental health experts it's people
like kyle rittenhouse it was the media's
emboldening of criminality they deemed
necessary to punish our evil racist
society and cowardly politicians
responded with policies that sponsored
this unsafe world so why wouldn't some
citizens step up to protect others who
else if not you
rittenhouse and others like him that's
who when you leave people with no
options this is what you're gonna get so
maybe written house acted in
self-defense but how did the media act
well they're not on trial but if they
were it would take a jury five minutes
to bring in a verdict of guilty
[Applause]
she bought an encyclopedia just to throw
at people
all right host of tons city
dutch the hero wow
she's more bubbly than a bottle of
champagne shaking in a paint mixer box
business corresponding susan lee
he's got something to say and it's
probably i didn't bathe today the loftus
party.com founder michael loftus
and her cats is tired of cleaning her
litter box fox news contributor cat tim
i meant to say you brought an
encyclopedia because you like throwing
the book at people but it came out of my
mouth garbled much like the prosecutor
what did you make of the prosecutor
today judge insane you know the
prosecutor was so
uh so damaged by rittenhouse taking the
stand and the prosecutor in fact was
damaged before rittenhouse even took the
stand because the main prosecution
witness understand two people are dead
one person was shot at and and and
injured by written house who said yeah i
had a loaded gun and i was actually
going toward kyle which is a classic
scenario where you actually say i'm
entitled to use steadily physical force
when deadly physical force is
confronting me so here you've got a case
where the d.a indicted this kid
24 48 hours after the crime that means
they didn't no investigation this is in
the aftermath of george floyd it's in
the aftermath of jacob blake shooting
it's in the middle of a riot when the
police are basically standing down and
you have this kid who's a uh he's a
police explorer he's a fire cadet he's a
certified cpr uh kid i mean he's a kid
who's trying to you know go in and do
some good things and i tell people i'm a
cpr instructor but i've never really
taken the course have you practiced it
on them i'll do what i can judge
what i can
i'm not picky yeah susan good to see you
how you doing i'm good how are you good
how's it going you've never practiced
cpr on me thank god well not that you're
aware
i don't even know what that means let's
not pursue that shall we a sexist would
say something like susan have you been
watching this i mean what i find
interesting is the prosecution is trying
to say he had no right to self-defense
even though he was beaten with a
skateboard he had a gun pointed at him
and the prosecutor actually said well
they never shot you
you have to be shot in order to fight
back right all true yes i don't want to
make him a hero because he's not right
he shouldn't be transporting firearms
across state lines you shouldn't have
been there in the first place but i
think you're right i mean all this
lawlessness and this chaos and motivates
these vigilantes like kyle rittenhouse
so what was he supposed to do right i
don't know see i i was thinking about
this i was thinking about okay so going
across state line sounds like he took
amtrak but it's like where it's where he
works it's where his dad lives yeah so
it's close it's 14 minutes he went there
every day that's where he works so i'm
thinking okay if i were 17 and i
realized that my city was going to hell
and i was a young kid who was trying to
do good things no you would not what
what a real
absolutely not what i don't like going
out in public
you're not gonna go as a child and get
an ar-15
but that you know i don't know i mean
and that's good because
that's good i mean i agree look i
obviously this was self-defense it's
ridiculous to say it's anything but
self-defense you can also say that being
a 17 year old kid that's like all right
school's out i know what i'm doing on
tuesday i'm gonna go get an ar-50 like
weird right like
i'm not a mom but i would not want my
kids playing with that kid no fairness
fair enough i would say like if i i
don't my kid the little billy gutfeld
was grabbing ar-15 and had no idea billy
no no no no no let me we'll i'll buy you
some chick-fil-a and we'll watch uh
we'll watch baywatch doesn't mean that's
reference
but
but
if if he was truly earnest and and
believed that he was trying to help
people right i mean just i don't think
he has to be a hero in order for it to
be self-defense i think that's a very
important point
that he just thank you i've got so many
of them stressful you have so many
voices in your head telling you oh that
is true too but again
self-defense you don't have this way the
constitution's there for a reason you
don't have to be this upstanding person
in order to be able to defend yourself
against somebody that is literally in
the act of trying to shoot you that's a
that's a good point okay loftus uh good
to see you stop by goodwill on the way
over here
oh you're so amazing i'm getting the
deals i'm getting the deals
i'm like a seal and a dumpster up in
this [ __ ] you need to make a decent
living and you're taking clothes that
would be you know a transient could have
worn
maybe did
you hear them after the transients are
done with them yeah it's true like yeah
all the clothes that you wear belong to
people who are no longer living
and it throws the search dogs off
everybody wins what's your take on this
i love this kid okay and it's exactly it
goes back to what you were saying this
is what happens when there's lawlessness
well she said that
when you don't have credit when you're
done
but when you don't have the police
stepping up and everybody's just
watching things burn what citizens
aren't going to step forward and try to
do refuge it's a second amendment
absolutely and shame on the fbi
they had footage that exonerated this
kid that they just mysteriously found
right when that is the point of what
they're doing when you politicize the
criminal justice system when you don't
even want to find out what the facts are
what the evidence is so that you can
indict this person that everyone on the
left is saying he's a member of a
militia he's a vigilante no he's not a
vigilante this is a kid who went there
they've got him on video he's actually
cleaning um
you know curse words on a wall that
they've got video of him he had body
armor that he got from a police force
when he was a police explorer or
whatever and he gave it to his friend he
didn't go there to kill anybody he
really didn't i mean this is a kid who's
filling a gap yeah absolutely and the
fbi couldn't have like
can't come forward with that video a
little bit quicker were they too busy
tracking down parents at a pta meeting
domestic terrorists and they said he was
a domestic terrorist so parents and kyle
are both domestic terrorists right
that's the tough gig right now you're
the the the uh the operator at the fbi
what do you got fentanyl please hold uh
what do you got domestic please hold oh
oh oh we got a missing diary from a
biden girl send everyone send everyone
you go that's a shame yeah i want to
know what's in that diary oh yeah
you know i bet there's some some dream
journaling some really good dream
journaling something about a kid in
chemistry class
i'm into that stuff oh where am i going
i don't know i should probably go to a
commercial i like it when you narrate
your own life though
it even disturbs me when i say my
thoughts out loud all right hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else